Kourtney Kardashian and new beau Jonas  Benjamin's hot streak continues  [Music]  the couple has been living it up in  France spending quality time in San  Tropez this week on Thursday the two  were spotted again this time hitting up  late club 55 the mother of three rocked  a sheer black bodysuit with  strategically placed white stars she  finished the look with unbuttoned denim  cutoffs  as for yonas the 20-something model kept  it cool with a black and white dress  shirt and gray athletic pants from the  looks of it these two were in good  spirits as they held hands making their  way to the tres chic beach club the duo  also hit up a local carnival  that's Cortney right they're coming for  onus in a bumper car the lovebirds also  partied at another French hotspot the  night before an eyewitness told ET quote  Cortney and Yanis were cute together  they seemed very comfortable with each  other  [Music]